زميل عبد الرحمن العصيمي اللي راح يتحدث
عن خبر هيك لافه حجه تركيه
تذهب الى اداء فريضه الحج في السعوديه وهو
ماسكين انا شايفته حرانه كتير تحت الشمس
اعذرنا
الخبر حلو يعني الجو الحين على البحر قلنا
صباح الخير عادل صباح الخير راوي انا
علشانكم اجلس يعني سنين طويله
فعلا موسم الحج هذا العام عادل وراوي
سيكون ملفتا للانظار وصل قبل ايام قليل
الفوج الاول من حجاج بيت الله الحرام من
الجمهوريه التركيه لهذا العام يضم الوفد
الاول 100 و 178 حاجا متوقع ان يصل عدد
الحجاج الاتراك لهذه السنه طبعا حوالي 188
الف حاج طبعا استقبالهم بالورود والتمور
والعديد من الهدايا طبعا
الملفت للنظر هذا العام هذه الحاجه ربما
الان تظهر معنا على الشاشه يصل عمرها
قرابه تسعين عاما
هذه الحاجه
وغيرها من الحجاج من خلال تغطيات اعاده
راويه للسنوات الماضيه لموسم الحج دائما
ما يلفت نظري حرص كبار السن على اداء هذه
الفريضه والقدوم الى المشاعر المقدسه رغم
التعب والمشقه وفي نفس الوقت بالكثير من
الخدمات تقدم لهؤلاء كبار الله يطعمنا
ويطعمكم عادل امين والله يتقبل صالح
الاعمال
كثير من الناس خليه على اداء هذه الفريضه
قصه السعوديه مع الفضاء ما اكتفيتوا
بالارض وين رايحين
نعم عادل يعني حرص كبير من السلطات
السعوديه وتحديدا الجهات التعليميه على
الابتعاث في مجال الفضاء طبعا حساب الرسمي
لبرنامج خادم الحرمين الشريفين الابتعاد
على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر اعلن عن
قرب اطلاق البرنامج التحضيري للابتعاث في
تخصصات الفضاء طبعا البرنامج اوضح بان
البرنامج التحضيري يستهدف دعم وتمكين
ابناء الوطن لحصول على القبول الجامعي في
افضل الجامعات العالميه في مجال الفضاء
طبعا لتحقيق تطلعات السعوديه في هذا
المجال طبعا هذه
الاعلان او هذا الاعلان ياتي بعد نجاح
رحله ريانه وعلي الى الفضاء ووصولهم الى
السعوديه قبل ايام نعلم راويه وعادل بان
الفضاء سيكون هو لغه المستقبل من ناحيه
الانترنت والاتصالات والبنيه التحتيه
اللوجستيه لقطاع الاتصالات بشكل عام في
السعوديه حريصه جدا على ان تكون حاضره في
هذا المجال قواك الله شكرا جزيلا عبد
الرحمن العصيمي وروح اقعد بالظلم خلاص
خلاص
لمتابعه المزيد الكبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات